ah  [Music]  these no no banana great  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  two weeks in Europe is gonna be great  I'm just gonna enjoy my trip hang out  with them Joe feel like really pretty  and therefore I have value no no that's  not what I meant  I'm messing with you she really likes me  that's really nice  so nice to finally meet you  spider-man hear Nick Fury put some  clothes on let's go for a ride  Nick Fury just hijacked our summer  vacation  [Music]  get gifts Parker but we have a job to do  you going to step up or not  we're all alone  friends are in trouble  what are you gonna do about it  you don't want any part of this  who is that guy he's like Iron Man and  Thor rolled into one he's no spider-man  what is it with you and spider-man what  he looks out for the neighbor it has a  dope suit in my really respective sub  you